because I I I really to this day
couldn't care less about standup I
always wanted to be an actor that's how
I saw the you're amazing at and you've
always been amazing at acting I always
say capable at that you know because if
what was that dramatic series that you
were on on NBC Crime Story Crime Story
you were amazing on that that was a
serious dramatic that was a Ganga show
right that sesi I always told this story
this is great so I do this series it's
Michael man after he did Miami Vice
right
and I forgot about it because I
auditioned five months before I ever got
the part you know Bonnie Timberman who
was one of the biggest casting agents in
Hollywood put me on tape and after two
three days you don't hear something you
forget about it you know so five months
later I'm visiting Brooklyn
you know from from Hollywood and my
mother's waking me up going your agent
keeps calling you got to you got to call
back and I go no they're going to bother
me with the with the Bruce Willis I was
supposed to do Bruce wills's first movie
Blind Date very small part it was
basically dancing and talking like
Travolta in a club scene but I was also
playing it was Memorial Day weekend and
I was booked to do rascal comedy club in
West Orange and I was a big drawer there
and it was a big club and it's 425 seats
and they got basically six shows sold
out for me and this is before the career
took off right okay so I was loyal to
the club and instead of I was supposed
to film after that weekend and go to
Hollywood on
Monday but they called and said we need
you Friday so I I said I can't do it I
can't disappoint these people and you
know the club's going to lose just
thousands and thousands of dollars so I
blew off the movie to do the club the
next day which is Friday my mother's
waking me up to the agents keep calling
I go ma they're going to bother me with
the Bruce Willis thing I'm not doing it
she goes well at least call back so you
know my mother was like me she smoked
120s I smoke cigarettes I don't I
haven't smoked in like years I just hold
them what are 120s I don't know what
that is like longer cigarettes you know
my mother's where I got the dice
attitude believe it or not I always I I
didn't know why uh when I listen to you
and watch you I always think oh this is
like an older Jewish
woman but yeah that's where I got the
attitude you know well she's a New
Yorker through she number parents number
one she looked like Liz Taylor beautiful
lady yes so when she would come up to
destroy a teacher of mine for saying the
wrong thing to me she'd come in wearing
the fur coat the hair black blown out
the cigarette lit in those days you know
was crazy but she went to your school
and re the
teacher all right I don't want to lose
okay Finish okay go ahead okay all right
so I called the agent I'm having coffee
with my mother I'm not doing the Bruce
Willis thing I'm I'm doing the club I
call the agent and my mother sees this
look come over my face as I'm talking to
the agent because what the agent's
telling me is you you were just hired
for five seasons of Michael man's new
show Crime Story right you know and
they're telling me you know every year
the bumps and the money I'm going to get
and I can't believe I just got a series
I can't even believe and you got to fly
out after your show Sunday night go to
Chicago to be in the 2hour movie cuz it
was a 2hour movie and then they would do
the
episodes and I'm like I couldn't believe
it because this Michael man this is
Miami Vice you know which was a big hit
show at the time and Michael Man became
a huge movie direct right yeah Michael
Michael man used to sit you know what he
loved what's his most famous movies just
for the listeners well just uh uh one of
the most commercial would be Ali
Will Smith Ali movie which which is
unreal you know right he lasted a moh
heagan uh heat right you know with
Pacino and daero you know I mean just
one of the greatest I nearly had the
seore part in the in heat because
Michael man loved me as an actor okay
but this is the joke of Crime Story now
just so you know scusi took Crime Story
when he saw Crime Story
and he did the movie Casino after that
because Crime Story was a real story
about those criminals like the the uh um
daero and peshi I was the daero
character in crime story yeah and Tony
Dennison who played Ray Luca was the
peshy character in casino but the reason
he did the movie it was a real story
right only in the movie he didn't have
the cops you know chasing the gangsters
like he did in crime story right that's
why it was a period piece set in the 60s
and 70s did you enjoy it was that a good
uh I was so thrilled to get that part
you know like I I couldn't believe it I
really couldn't believe it and you do
you think that that was the big lunch
for you well no what what happened was
this is what's funny now let's say it
was this day and age and they put Crime
Story on HBO it would have lasted like
The Sopranos lasted but it was one of
those shows it's like have you seen this
it was like either ABC or NBC NBC so
nobody really catapulted and you had
guys on there like David Caruso
everybody from that show took off um uh
Kevin spacy all these at Michael Matson
you know Dennis finina Bill smich all
these great actors and actresses I'm
going to be honest with you I don't know
who bill smich is well he wound up with
his own show after that a 1H hour drama
you know um yeah so many great actors
like if you look no it was great it was
just a well it was a very classy well
acted well-directed well- written show
which was a surprise because we being in
in the comedy community knew you as an
impressionist and as a singer and as a
comedian
and the only reason I did that hoe was
instead of going to acting school once a
month once a week I figured be on a club
stage every night and develop my own
method of acting that's why I did
standup and that's why I walked away
from The Impressions and started doing a
dice like character when I was 23 you
know really I didn't know that yeah I
couldn't kill us you could you could
quiz me about the history of Comedy I go
I don't know who that
is
he